Now, a lot of people
don't know this,
uh, but we have something
special tonight.
Okay, the Trump campaign
actually granted
The Nightly Show exclusive
backstage access.
I'm not making this up.
(laughter)
Okay, I might be making it up.
I might be making up,
but I'm really not making it up.
Okay, backstage access
to Donald Trump
in the moments leading up
to his big speech,
and we were able to capture
some very compelling,
intimate, uh, moments.
Take a look.
(people cheering)
The situation in Turkey
is a real mess,
and we all know that it was
crooked Hillary's fault,
but, look, we got
to restore order, okay,
and we got to monitor
the situation.
We got to show our strength.
We got to get tough, like real
tough, like unbelievably t...
-look, I got to go.
-All right.
What the hell happened
in Turkey?
Problems,
got a lot of problems.
So many problems
in our country, folks.
Believe me.
Mu-slims. Mu-slims.
Obama. Obama.
Black, black, black. Obama.
MAN: No, come on, this is
the perfect time. Come on.
-MAN 2: Uh...
-Mr. Trump, look who's here.
-Hey.
-LeBron James.
You were absolutely fantastic
against the Warriors.
-My God, you were good.
-(chuckles)
Oh, no. I'm-I'm your new,
um, Middle East advisor.
It's-it's, um...
What are you doing?
Oh, good. Uh, what are you gonna
be wearing later on tonight?
Oh, my God, I love that outfit.
-It's so fantastic, so sexy.
-Mr. Trump, five minutes.
Uh, look, I got to go, Ivanka.
...so I put it on. As I'm doing
that, the guy behind me,
I hear him saying,
"Oh, I've got the wrong coat."
So now there's two of us. We
obviously have the wrong coat.
I realize here's a connection.
I look over.
Who do you think I saw,
everybody?
Actually, I can't remember.
Actually...
Melania, who-whose coat was it?
-MELANIA (accented):
Regis Philbin. -Oh. (hisses)
God, that Slovenian accent,
it cuts through me,
literally, like a knife. Um...
Regis Philbin.
(light laughter)
-Oh, that's great.
-What are the chances?
-Great story. -Crazy.
-Unbelievable, right?
That is the perfect story.
Unbelievable.
I don't tell it to most people.
Most people want to hear it--
I don't tell it, okay?
But it's the perfect story.
I save it a lot.
Guys, guys,
I just found a Pikachu.
Oh. And there's a Jigglypuff.
Look, my remarks
about the disabled
were taken out of context, okay?
Jews. The Jews. Jews.
I can't believe the crap that
these Never Trump protesters
pulled on the convention floor.
I mean, look,
I won every primary.
I mean,
I did fantastically well.
And now these party hacks want
to steal my nomination.
-(toilet flushing)
-(sighs)
And, by the way, that guy
from Alaska, the delegate,
he's a real asshole.
I was raised in a small town
in Southern Indiana
in a big family with
a cornfield in the backyard.
Although we weren't really
a political family,
the heroes of my youth were
President John F. Kennedy and...
Excuse me. Excuse me.
Excuse me.
I didn't say
all of them were rapists.
I said most of them.
IVANKA: ...to present to you
and to all of America
-my father and our next
president... -I can't do this.
I can't do it. It was a gag.
It was fun.
I was just doing it for fun.
I can't do it. Let me out.
Please. I got to get out
of here. It was all for fun.
Crooked Hillary can run
the country. I don't care.
Watch your step.
-♪ ♪
-(cheering and applause)
Unbelievable.
We'll be right back.